Bộ có phòng ngàn em muốn chỉ nếu một quyền bố của nội nước này đã phát động một cuộc tấn công
cuối môi lớn nhắn vào cơ cơ sở trọng iếu của quay nà để đắt chả buộc tấn công
chưa đó của kia vào dính thượng của tổng thống là đi miệp của chiến.
Tình bố của bộ có phòng ngàn cho biết, lực lượng của chẳng ngàn đã tiến hàng một
cuộc tấn công cuối môi lớn sử dụng vũi tầm xa, độ chính xa cao được phóng
được các bệ phóng chiến bộ và chiến biển.
Bóng vệ thống tên lửa gì động tầm xa, o rest neck nhắn vào cơ sở sả suốt
bây bài không người lại và hạt tân năng lực phụ vụ tổ hợp kương như có phòng của quay nà.
Ngài cũng khẳng định đã đánh chúng tất cả các mục tiêu và mọi của tập ký của quay nà trong tình lạc đều dựa
dạch chả.
Chứ đó ngả em chỉ nâng mẹ hai ngoài trường ngà sư về la broc cho biết,
u khuy này đã tập ký gên và dính thượng thống ngàn ở tình nắp có rốt
bằng chỉ môi mấy bài không người lại ua vê về phần mình
ua quay nà đã phủ nhận thực hiện bộ tấn công và cho sang ngà được ra thông tin xa lạc
về chiến dạch.